well the golden knights were expected to
play the saint louis blues at t-mobile
but covid
caused the nhl to cancel tonight's game
sports director chris matthews joins us
live with the latest developments
that were announced this morning chris
well thank you christian yeah knights
general manager kelly mccrimmon was
hoping this day would not come
but it seems nobody's immune to the
vicious virus following their game two
days ago
he said no players tested positive for
the virus but a coach did
so they had to get approval from the nhl
to play that game with the silver
knights coaches assisting him
on the bench but today golden knights
following up on the release
by the nhl saying that a player and
another coach had to skate into the
nhl's covid protocols
knight's defenseman there he is alex
petrangelo will have to self-isolate
along with another night's coach the
team released in a statement saying
the nhl has announced that as a result
of a player and another member of the
vegas golden knights coaching staff
entering the nhl's covet protocols the
team's game tonight against the st
louis blues will be postponed the
knights didn't take to the ice but guess
what the silver knights did in fact
then a former knight derek england
helping out because the silver knight
staff as we mentioned
had planned on helping out with
tonight's game so derek pitched in
talked to him yesterday afternoon and um
you know i i uh earlier in the day seen
what was going on so you know i
kind of uh just offered any way i can
help
the team and um you know they called and
asked if i could do that and it was
no problem it's it's it's fun being out
there and especially with the young guys
getting to work with them and um
as of after this i i have no idea i'm up
in the air just like everyone else but
uh
you know like i said i'm i'm here to
help in any way i
can and we'll go from there no word on
when the knights game will be made up as
for the silver knights they are
expecting to play a preseason game
against san jose
at the orleans arena this weekend we'll
have much more coming up at six
including
more with derrick england his second
time back on that orleans ice
since he played there about 15 years ago